i'm brenkov it's good to have you with
us we begin tonight with the
palestinians the israelis and
accusations of
war crimes today the international
criminal court opened an investigation
into
alleged war crimes committed in the
palestinian territories
since 2014. the probe will target both
the israeli military
and the palestinian militant group hamas
it comes after the icc
ruled last month that it had
jurisdiction over territories
occupied by israel including the west
bank and the gaza strip
the palestinian authority has welcomed
the investigation while israeli prime
minister benjamin netanyahu
has accused the court of hypocrisy and
anti-semitism
all right for more now we can go to
jerusalem our correspondent tanya kramer
is on the story for us good evening to
you tanya
despite israel's attempts to postpone
the decision the prosecutor
has announced the opening of an
investigation into war crimes what more
do we know tonight
well as you said that has been a long
process after
a five-year-long nearly five-year-long
preliminary
investigation and also after the
decision
back in february just last month by a
panel of three judges
who had ruled that indeed the icc has
jurisdiction
over the occupied west bank gaza and
east jerusalem now the prosecutor the
chief prosecutor
fatou ben sudar had referred this matter
to the panel of three judges back in
december 2019
when she concluded that there are
grounds to open
a formal investigation against israeli
and palestinian
individuals for alleged war crimes but
she had to refer to the panel of
three charges to get their opinion on
the jurisdiction
now we are expecting um this
investigation to deal
with everything that happened after 2014
the gaza
war between israel and hamas
then the issue of construction of
settlements in the occupied territory
as well as possibly the
actions of the israeli military against
palestinian protesters
along the gaza fence during 2018. so
today
uh for two ben sudai in her statement
also said
that she will decide on the priorities
in the coming
weeks also given you know the challenges
uh by the pandemic
and also the workload of the office of
the prosecutor
yeah you bring up a good point too the
list of possibilities there is is very
long
we know that the israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu he has called this
decision anti-semitic
and absurd what can he do now
well that is a good question of course
israel also has now period of time
to answer to this opening of the
investigation but
the reaction by the israeli prime
minister
doesn't come as a surprise already last
month he had called that decision by the
judges
by the icc as anti-semitic this has been
a long-held view
by israel that the court is overstepping
its mandate and that this
is a highly politicized politicized
issue and that the court
actually doesn't have uh jurisdiction
now we also have to mention this is kind
of a consensus in israeli politics we
heard from several other
political leaders tonight being highly
critical
of this decision by the icc not by all
parties but by most
i have to mention that because we're
also in the middle of an election
campaign there are elections in three
weeks and
some of his political rivals will
certainly use this against mr netanyahu
because it happened on his watch
but again this is a decision that will
go beyond a party politics and beyond
this election this will keep
israeli politics busy for years to come
so on the palestinian side of course
this decision was warmly welcomed we had
a statement from the foreign ministry
saying that this will lead to
accountability
and justice and you have to say the
palestinians have been working
very diligently on this issue to
internationalize to go and join
international organizations
and so they hope that some somehow
israel will held accountable for what it
does here in this conflict
okay dw's tonya kramer with the latest
tonight in jerusalem tanya as always
thank you